why don't you give a three-minute
synopsis i know that's difficult
as to your theory for those who are
unacquainted
well gosh
so i've been working on this for like 40
years so it's a little bit hard to
compress but but i suppose as gradually
as one learns more about what one's
talking about it becomes easier to
explain
all right let's
talk about physics and kind of um
what's the universe made of so to speak
and i think one of the things that has
been
the the first question is
uh
we think about things like space and
time and the traditional view of
something like space has been
it's
this thing that you put things in
it it isn't a thing itself it's just
sort of a background
and you get to specify a position here
or there in space that's been kind of
the idea of space
since uh euclid and so on
so one of the
the the basic points in uh kind of the
the models that we've developed is uh
there's something space is made of
something just like a fluid like water
you might think of it as just a
continuous fluid
where you can like uh
put something anywhere in the fluid
actually you can't it's made of discreet
molecules bouncing around and so we
think it is with space
that uh sort of at the lowest level at
very small scales space is just made of
a whole collection of discrete elements
we can think of them as like geometrical
points
but they're not points that have a known
position in anything they're just
discreet elements
and the only thing we know about those
elements is how they're connected to
other elements so it's kind of like the
uh the the points since
that exists in the universe
are sort of friends with other points
and we build up this whole network of
connections between points
and so our our universe as it is today
might have maybe 10 to the 400 of these
uh of these sort of atoms of space
that make it up so sort of the first
point is everything in the universe is
just space
so what uh
all of the particles and electrons and
quarks and all those kinds of things
they're all just features of this
details of the connections between these
atoms of space
so sort of the first thing is what's the
universe made of it's made of space what
space made of space is made of this
giant network of of nodes giant network
of discrete elements
and we don't even from that know why a
space three-dimensional the thing can be
connected in any way at once what
happens is that on a large scale
something which is discretely connected
like that can behave as if it is for
example a three-dimensional manifold on
a large scale and and for example one
thing that can happen and we think does
happen in the early universe is that the
universe goes from being essentially an
infinite dimensional uh network where
things are everything sort of connected
to everything else to this sort of more
or less three-dimensional so far as we
know right now perfectly
three-dimensional though we suspect
there are some dimension fluctuations um
that exists today so okay so that's sort
of what space is
then what's time
well
the the the point is the idea is that
there are these definite rules that will
say if there's a piece of network that
looks like this transform it into one
that looks like that and that's
continually happening throughout this
this network that represents uh the
structure of space and the content of
the universe and so what's what um uh
what we're what we're seeing then is a
sort of progression of all of these
little updates of this network that
represents space and that progress of
all those updates corresponds to the
progress of time and one of the things
that's unusual about that is for the
last hundred years or so in physics
people have kind of assumed space and
time is sort of the same kind of thing
one knows about relativity one knows
that sort of there's there's processes
that kind of trade off space with time
yet in our theory space is this
extension of this this as it is turns
out to be a hypograph this network
basically and time is the progressive
sort of inexorable computation of the
next configuration of the network based
on rewriting the previous configuration
so one of the things that is sort of an
early thing to realize in our models is
this question of of so how does things
how does something like relativity arise
well the answer is if you are an entity
embedded within this network
it turns out that the only thing you are
ever sensitive to is kind of the the the
network of causal relationships between
updating events and and it turns out
there's a few more steps here but it
turns out that uh with with certain
conditions on the way those updatings
work it is the case
that uh uh
basically special relativity comes out
of that we can talk in more detail about
how that works
so
the next thing that happens is this the
space just made up from this network
it's sort of the the
the the continuum limit of this network
in the sense it's like you've got these
atoms of space underneath and then a
large scale space is like kind of a
fluid made up of lots of atoms um that
uh behaves in the continuous way that
we're used to to perceiving it and then
it turns out that um
you can get space in any other
dimensions you can get space with
different kinds of curvature
one of the big results
is that you can get
uh the the the way the curvature arises
in space
is exactly the way that einstein's
equations for gravity say curvature
should arise roughly energy momentum
mass these are all associated with
levels of activity in the network and
roughly levels of activity in the
network produce curvature in the network
in just the way that einstein's
equations say that uh uh energy momentum
in in
physical space time should produce
curvature in in space
so that's that's a pretty important
thing i actually knew that back in the
1990s that these models um could uh uh
reproduce general relativity reproduce
einstein's equations
so then the next big sort of pillar of
20th century physics is quantum
mechanics they're really literally
probably two or maybe three pillars of
20th century physics
general relativity the theory of gravity
uh quantum mechanics
and also to some extent statistical
mechanics which also uh sort of comes
out from the formalism of these models
but it's uh maybe it's not the first
thing to explain here
but um
so how does quantum mechanics arise well
first thing is what is quantum mechanics
what is the what is the important
feature of quantum mechanics basically
in classical physics before
the 1920s or so
people thought that in physics there
were definite equations of motion
things behave in definite ways you throw
a ball it goes in a definite trajectory
when
what quantum mechanics says is no that
doesn't isn't what happens instead there
are many possible histories that develop
and the the universe has many possible
histories and all we get to be sensitive
to is some kind of aggregated
probability of what happens not knowing
specifically what the history of the
universe is
well it turns out in our models that's
something that inevitably works that way
and um
what happens is we're talking about sort
of the rewriting of this big network
and the point is that there isn't just
one
possible rewrite that happens at any
given time there are many possible
rewrites and each of those different
possible rewrites represents essentially
taking the universe in a different path
of history but the critical fact is that
just as there are there might be two
possible rewrites that could happen and
they produce a branching of two parts of
history so also it will turn out when
there are other rewritings that can
happen later that actually these
branches can merge so you end up with
something which is this whole graph of
possible histories we call it a
multi-way graph and in this multi-way
graph there is both branching and
merging of histories and that uh that
process of branching and merging of
histories
that
ends up being the story of quantum
mechanics basically and one of the
things that sort of a thing to to think
about is
when we look at
they have this whole multi-way graph of
all these branching histories of the
universe
and we say let's
let's imagine that we are observing that
we are
uh it's a little bit hard to imagine
because what's happening is we our
brains our minds are the are themselves
embedded in this multi-way graph
so just as the universe is breaking into
all these different uh paths of history
so too are our brains breaking into all
these different parts of history so in a
sense what's happening is it's a
branching brain observing a branching
universe you have to kind of think about
what is how do you how do you kind of
how does a how does the brain how does
our mind make sense of that universe
and what you realize is that you're kind
of defining what we might call reference
frames
kind of quantum reference frames they're
analogous to the reference frames that
we think about in relativity where
reference frames typical inertial frames
are things like you are at rest you're
traveling at a certain velocity
et cetera et cetera et cetera there's
kind of a quantum analog of those and
that's the way that we perceive this
multi-way graph of possible histories
and so when we say let's pick a
particular quantum reference frame
corresponds to more or less a particular
time
um
and
let's then ask what is the sort of slice
of this multi-way graph
defined by this quantum reference frame
what we have is all these different
possible histories and they're all kind
of laid out
in some sense histories can be close to
each other if they had common ancestors
recently histories could be further away
from each other if they didn't have a
common ancestor for a long time and so
on all these histories are kind of laid
out in some kind of space we call that
bronchial space the space of branches
the space of quantum branches
and that branchial space it's not like
physical space it's not like something
where you have ordinary motion from one
place to another but in branchial space
um there is it's it's a layout of
possible histories of the possible
states of the universe effectively
so one of the things that i find really
neat
is that you can talk about motion in
physical space you can talk about uh for
example uh you know even ever since
newton we've we've kind of had this
principle that if things aren't acted on
by a force they will keep going in a
state of uniform motion so it's kind of
like things go in straight lines if you
leave them by themselves
and kind of einstein's big idea in
general artillery was to think that yes
things do go in kind of straight lines
in the sense that their shortest paths
geodesic paths
but
space can be curved and then what might
be to the thing kind of its straight
line path to the outside is a curved
path and because that curvature is
associated with energy momentum that is
what leads to the effect of gravity so
to speak so physical space that's how
things work
turns out in branch shield space they
work in essentially exactly the same way
except now in terms of the equations of
gravity we have
the equations of quantum mechanics and
quantum field theory
and essentially what's happening is that
there are sort of paths in branchial
space that are being followed and we are
seeing deflections of those paths
actually associated also with energy
momentum and the way those deflections
work
uh exactly gives one the path integral
of quantum mechanics so the the thing
that's really pretty neat is i mean one
of many very neat things but one thing
that i just found
really was a very wow moment about a
year and a bit ago now gosh i can't
believe it so long um the uh
congratulations by the way it's um uh
yeah well time time inexorably moves
forward right so it's it's um no but i
think the the um
uh
that you know sort of a wow moment was
realizing that that the einstein
equations in physical space
are basically the same thing as the
feynman path integral in brown shale
space so in a sense general relativity
and quantum mechanics are the same
theory just played out in these
different kinds of space
and uh that has a lot of implications
because it kind of shows one
how there are correspondences between
general relativity and quantum and
quantum mechanics and they're sort of
the sort of uh i don't know
intersectional cases uh when one's
dealing with black holes and so on but
so that's a that's at least one level of
um
uh the story of our models of physics
and um
uh you know a lot of detail a lot of
things that are now it's now clear yes
we really can reproduce exactly what
happens in you know black hole mergers
we can reproduce what happens in quantum
computing we can reproduce all these
other kinds of things and we're starting
to have kind of ideas about
uh you know a lot of i know a lot of
experimental physicists who keep on
saying to me when are you going to give
us actual experiments to do and we're
getting closer you know it's no point in
telling them uh there's a lot of actual
physics and astrophysics and so on to be
done to work out exactly what to look
for but i mean another direction here
that that um uh is well there's several
directions i mean one is kind of
understanding
um
i've had sort of in the last few months
kind of a deeper understanding of uh
what kind of observers of the universe
we actually are
and how consciousness relates to
what kinds of things we do and don't
observe about the universe and what
consequences that has for the kinds of
laws the kinds of physical laws that we
believe are going on in the universe
that's one direction another direction
is um uh trying to understand if we can
say yes we have this simple rule that's
updating this hypergraph and so on and
then you say why is it that simple rule
not another one what i've realized
recently what we realized a while ago
but it's become a lot crisper now
is this idea that actually there is the
um
in some sense the universe can be
running all possible rules and we are we
are seeing some kind of reference frame
not in physical space or in branchial
space but in this thing we call rule
space the space of all possible rules
we are essentially picking a particular
description language a particular
reference frame with which to understand
the universe and so the sort of paradox
of why or this this sort of conundrum of
why does one why does the universe
follow one particular rule and not
others turns out the answer is it
follows all possible rules and we are
just at some place in rural space
observing it in a particular way and
that has uh
the big surprise to me recently last
month or so has been realizing that i
actually think we can get a serious
answer to a question like why does the
universe exist
and as a matter of fact the thing that
comes out of that is
the realization that as soon as we say
the universe exists and as soon as we
give that argument we are forced into a
position that mathematics in some sense
fundamentally exists too which is
something you know people like plato
have said but something very different
from the way that people have uh
assumed the foundations of mathematics
work so you asked me for a three minute
i'm sure that wasn't three minutes but
um summary but that's
i mean i i have
not talked about a lot of the
intuitional underpinnings that are
necessary for this theory of physics
concepts like the principle of
computational equivalence computational
irreducibility and so on i mean what's
basically happened in the building of
this this theory is
uh it's sort of the result of well it's
i guess it's now 40 years of my
uh activities um that
in the first of the first layer is
probably
you know i i used to do sort of
traditional quantum field theory general
relativity particle physics kinds of
things so i i know that stuff fairly
well although although it's kind of it's
a rip van winkle type situation for me
because that was 40 years ago and i'm
right now kind of um uh it's it hasn't
changed as much as you might have
thought a field might change like if i
look at biology over that period of time
you know there were all these things in
biology where it's like i learned stuff
about cells 40 years ago 45 years ago
whatever and it was like that's an
organelle of unknown function and now
there's a whole you know vast journals
devoted to exactly what you know the
golgi complex does or something
something like this so so in a sense
that field has advanced a lot more than
physics over that period of time but i
think um the uh you know sort of that
layer then there's the layer that i've
spent years building practical
technology for actually computing things
and
both the the
level of understanding of how formal
systems work that has come with the
process of designing
wolfram language and mathematica and so
on that has been really critical to what
we built
and then the very practicalities of you
know so we actually have an environment
in which to do experiments we can you
know do graph theory easily and things
like this
and then
the whole new kind of science
development of what simple programs do
understanding principles of that and so
on and i realized there's a there's in
the end a fairly tall tower that we've
ended up relying on uh to uh uh to kind
of construct this theory and i you know
to me is this funny feeling because you
know
i'm i'm really excited that we managed
to get this done and it's gone a lot
better than i expected it would go
but it almost didn't happen i mean it
very very nearly didn't happen
and you know the question that i might
ask myself is if it hadn't happened
when would it have happened otherwise
and the answer is i don't know 50 years
100 years i don't know
it wasn't it wasn't a thing where you
know it wasn't like all the stars were
lined up for everybody so to speak it
was a particular
series of things that are kind of the
story of my life and then people like
jonathan who had their own uh things
that they bring into this um you know
it's kind of a an unexpected and unusual
alignment plus it turned out
we managed to get a lot further than we
ever expected to get
so it's um uh
anyway that that's that's a little bit
of an outline of of um kind of uh
where we are i suppose i mean there's
there's a lot more to say about the
details of what's happening with the
models and and how we compute things
from them and so on but you ask for a
basic introduction that's my attempt at
a basic introduction